foreign
that came out exactly one year ago today
and it has not aged well Ken so you're
talking about uh uh Matt Damon Matt
Damon it was only funny in that it was
so cheesy serious you know I remember it
was like these big bold historical books
do we have it I think we have it we have
the actual commercial oh let's roll this
play it
with those who almost adventured who
almost achieved
But ultimately
for them it proved to be too much oh
devastating then there are others the
ones who embrace the moment climb up
snowy mountains look at this guy and
commit yes and in these moments of Truth
these men and women the airplane the
Wright brothers
mere mortals didn't get that one they're
just in the club as they peer over the
edge
they calm their minds
and steal their nerves
with four simple words that have been
whispered by the Intrepid since the time
of the Romans wait for it fortune favors
the brave
crypto.com yeah so okay so I remember
watching that that was perfect that's
like I thought it was a Velveeta
commercial like we were gonna see so a
block of cheese like float through the
sky so bad and uh and so this is fun
because this was a year ago and you want
you know there's a term now the kids use
on social media what is it like this
tweet didn't age well oh yeah yeah
you've heard that phrase well this
commercial did not age well uh let's
just look at the numbers
uh by the way I like Matt Damon okay
none of this is an attack on Matt Damon
you know the guy got paid handsomely to
say all those ridiculously cheesy lines
uh had you uh uh calmed your mind
and did what Matt Damon told you to do
and you spent a thousand dollars uh
worth on bitcoin that day
um it was worth 60 608 back then near
its peak price which is pretty amazing
it would now just be worth three hundred
and forty dollars oh boy oh so I don't
know if fortune favors the brave or the
wise I think it's the wise now am I sane
I mean Dave and I have talked about this
you know just just kind of privately
about cryptocurrency I mean right now it
is so wildly speculative not just
because of the ups and downs but because
these kind of things rarely go
unregulated that's the whole point it's
going to be unregulated government well
guess what now the bite administration's
already come out and say well we're
going to come out with ours other world
government's going to do the same thing
and and so when something is unregulated
it's also unprotected and you can lose
your shirt and a whole lot of other
things so pretty interesting and and and
we have some fun at this because this is
why we preach wisdom
with money don't be speculative and take
this because Matt Damon could talk you
into going oh wow I want to be like
Orville uh Orville and Wilbur right and
I want to fly a plane and I want to
invest my brother's first names somebody
has to well done well it's you got to
make fun of me sometime during the show
today but I mean it's it's just it's
playing on our emotions right now to get
us to do something and then walk around
going hey
I'm Really Brave and what you really are
is your adult you're a [ __ ] if you make
a decision Financial like that with no
background no research and it's a wild
risk you might as well just take a
thousand dollars and burn it well for me
it's the long-term track record that's
what I always go back to right if I'm
gonna put my money in something I'm like
I just want to know
that there's like it's not everything's
being predictable right the market you
know who knows what's going to happen
after November in the midterms and the
market when you see something move like
like you don't know we don't have a
crystal ball but you can look over the
scope of time on something and for me if
it's my hard-earned money that I've
worked for
like I just wanted I want to put it
somewhere that I know right and have
pretty great certainty that over the
course of time right uh I'm gonna make
more on it so uh yeah the crypto thing
and it's so it's such a fascinating
thing because I just feel like so many
celebrities have jumped on it well of
course they jumped on they get paid
handsome money to do yeah I know but he
doesn't even know what cryptocurrency is
it's not like there's like an online
bank that all these you know that's like
it's just it's pretty funny just the
just that whole genre and they've
attracted the celebrity pop culture
aspect well our colleague George
Campbell likes to call crypto what does
he call Mary Kay for young men it's a
great line and I will say this really
quick before we move on the thing I love
about that commercial that is so
ridiculously funny is it's all about
these big bold moves and it shows a dude
making his move in a nightclub like what
was that doing in there I still don't
get this like here's here's a guy
climbing Mount Everest here's space
astronauts and then here's some dude hey
I just don't get it so anyway well one
year ago today the Matt Damon challenged
you the fortune Brave favors the brave
you wouldn't better off taking that a
thousand dollars and playing craps with
it in Vegas especially with me as you're
at your table you are the hottestine you
have the hot hand no question